Speaker 1: Let's try Andy in Nebraska
next. Andy, what is your question today?
You can jump right into it.
Speaker 3: Oh, wow. Hey,
I've got kind of a light hearted question for you.
Just about right wing media. Sorry, it's a little
disorienting to see and discord versus your, well,
edited audio on YouTube. It's about the Gutfeld
show. Because I think you mentioned at one point
that you've actually. Corresponded with Gutfeld.
Speaker 1: Greg Gutfeld, yes, I've exchanged
some, some Twitter DMs with him, yeah.
Speaker 3: So he. The show is I don't think
most of your viewers experience much of Fox
News like I came on to this show when I was at
work. I work as like a. I work on long shifts,
so it was a late night and the Gutfeld show came
on like, you know, it was the normal fox montage
of shows. And then the Gutfeld show came on, and
it was just this odd. Unusual paradox of like
trying to be a late night show.
Speaker 1: Well,
yeah, it's also got it's like a comedy show.
Andy, did you have a question for me today?
Speaker 3: Yes, I was just curious on your
thoughts on that and Fox News, because the
Gutfeld show is just fascinating to me.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the Joe, the show is a
joke. We've talked about how it tries to be a
comedy show and it fails. It's not funny and
it tries to be a news show and it fails and it's
not a news show. It's a very, very strange amalgam
of different things. Andrew Yang, who is on this
show, recently was recently on the Gutfeld show,
and it was very strange. I think that Fox
News has no idea what to do with that show.
And so they're kind of feeling around in the dark
and nothing really is working. So it'll be curious
to see whether that show even survives, and that's
something we're going to be following up on.
All right, everybody. That's all the
time I had today for calls. We're
going to take a break and go through
some of your emails and other things.
We will take calls again, and I look forward to
speaking to more of you coming up very, very soon